[Music]  Brown hook ankle hook knee hook  come here you can do the carousel to  switch and wrap  [Applause]  [Music]  - 40 % 160 I just want to take care of  my grandma maybe go shopping every once  in a while when I was a kid I always  wanted to work with animals I was close  these Wall Street guys you see in this  country I stole from everybody  hard-working people lost everything I'm  not one of these douchebags went to jail  the game is rigged and it does not  reward people who play by the rules  it's like robbing the bank except you  get the keys are you in these are my  co-workers jobs please  what if somebody calls the cops and says  what  in $5,000 at a strip club send help  would you say that things got out of  control so the guy went back three more  time he must have liked it my neck  we didn't do anything wrong you know  Tony won't let this happen I'm gonna  text it gave her her phone back  [Music]  [Music]